students are diving into computer code
for computer science education week
schools completed a so-called hour of
code this week the lessons are part of a
campaign created by code org this
nonprofit is working to foster an
interest in community in computer rather
science education and creat access in
schools nationwide nearly 500 million
students and educators all around the
world have learned basic computer coding
through the program since it started
four years ago code org co-founder and
CEO that's hottie or toby is here at the
table so we should thank you and your
twin brother for this thank you very
much for having me no we're really glad
that you're here howdy because you say
listen one hour of coding can change
your life most people are intimidated
and scared you say don't be scared yeah
we've had tens of millions of students
actually literally about 15% of all the
students on the planet have tried an
hour of code and what you learn in one
hour you don't become a coder in one
hour what you learn is that this isn't
as intimidating as what you see on TV
with people like typing ones and zeroes
showing up on the screen that's not how
it's done and especially in school you
can start as early as kindergarten and
the the tutorials you do that at that
age are so easy and so much fun but you
taught yourself to code at the age of
ten what I think is so fascinating about
you guys well a lot of people start
learning this field on their own and the
you know the reason we're trying to get
this into school is because every kid
has the opportunity or should have the
opportunity to learn but most aren't
going to be self-taught this is
something that should be integrated as
part of the school system so everybody
if they want to if they take to it has
that chance explain how it works I know
you helped push the Trump administration
to redirect 200 million dollars into
this and then Silicon Valley or the tech
industry followed with another 300 how
does that half a billion dollar in
computer science funding translate into
coding so the real the really use of
that money what's important to do is to
help America's teachers learn how to
teach computer science because if you
went to a school and said you know why
aren't you teaching this they'd say
because we don't have any teachers who
themselves learned it and if the
teachers don't know it and you know you
got to start the system somewhere and
the number one use of that money is to
Train existing teachers math teachers
English teachers history teachers so
they can teach a little bit of computer
science as part of the school
yeah one of the problems that you're
hearing from the corporate world when it
comes to hiring is that the jobs are
here we just don't have any people to
hire that I've trained it for for these
jobs and no offense to the math industry
you have some people saying not don't
teach trigonometry teach coding because
these are the courses and the skill sets
that the children of tomorrow's
generation are going to need are you
starting to see that change in school
districts around the country yet so
we're not saying don't teach something
this is be clear we don't want to pick
fights with trigonometry but we do think
party some people would say coding is
more useful than trying on trigonometry
there were more jobs and more money in
it
but I think education is important to
give people well-rounded background in
all sorts of things but what we think is
important is for school - at least
offered as an option the majority of
America's schools don't even offer a
choice to teach to learn computer
science and so if you're your kid is
going to a school that doesn't offer
they'll never have that chance what's
your basic explanation - to let people
know exactly what coding is you know
we've all heard the word we all think
it's it's it's very there are a lot of
numbers but what exactly does it do
writing code is basically giving a
computer instructions for something I
wanted to do um you know if you've ever
had an idea saying oh they should build
an app that does blah blah blah you know
first of all you should think I should
build an app okay but the way you would
build an app for a website is using
coding in this place in - we call that
female empowerment as of late and
talking about that in Silicon Valley
specifically more STEM jobs for women in
particular science technology math or
engineering you hear organizations like
girls who code what are you doing
specifically all it's important for the
guys to know how to do it but what are
you doing to tailor to women to bring
them on to the sector as well this is so
important and part of why we're trying
to get this into the school system is
when you teach something as part of
school you get much more balanced if you
look inside math actually the math
mathematics in high schools is equal
between girls and boys about 49 51 and
what we've done a code or we just
announced 10 million girls have accounts
on code.org and in fact if only one
percent of the girls for coding encode
org went on to study it in college
it would balance the disparity between
men and women I love it howdy part oh
he's so great to have you here thank you
so much thank you